thank you very much so yeah it's a
pleasure to be here
um my name is Alexander fossil I'm the
lead data scientist of the advanced
analytics team of alliance Germany and
the topic of my talk is about
explainable unsupervised anomaly
detection using Bayesian histograms so
let me briefly sketch the agenda I will
give you a quick introduction to what is
anomaly detection what is the definition
of an outlier and then give you a little
bit of a technical background regarding
the model that we proposed
and then also show you a python
implementation
phad a package that we have come up with
and then show you some benchmarking some
predictive performances how the metal is
model is doing
and finally give you an Outlook and a
quick summary
so
what is an outlier or an anomaly so
depending on really where and what kind
of literature or domain of research
you're looking at you might find
yeah different uh definitions if you
stick let's say with the statistics
definition
that's a relatively uh commonly used
definition due to Hawkins
um which says that an outlier is an
observation which deviates so much from
the other observations as to our
suspicions that it was generated by a
different mechanism and this already
suggests that there is some sort of data
generating process this is very much
statistics based so really normal data
objects somehow follow that generating
mechanism whereas abnormal or deviating
objects somehow deviate in some
statistical sense from this data
generating process
so there are
um yeah many industrial applications
obviously to anomaly detection and
outlier detection
for example fault detection quality
control and predictive maintenance or
weblog analytics when you think of
um yeah looking for unusual patterns in
in weblocks also in medical for example
Imaging Diagnostics to give an example
or in finance so banking insurance for
example
very very common application is
obviously fraud detection
in particular for
also important for Allianz and
natural science for example earth
science application sea surface
temperature anomalies and so forth so
um
you can somehow classify the the
different approaches that that are out
there in the literature
um
around certain let's say categories
one would be if the method you you're
using is probabilistic in nature or
non-probabilistic
um on the other hand it's about the way
you can use Supervision in your data so
is it an unsupervised semi-supervised or
even let's say some sort of imbalanced
supervised learning problem
or something you know in between like a
Pew learning problem is it an ensemble
um that you're using
um or is it um single model then the how
do you measure let's say deviations or
for example do you use the distances
between observations in the feature
space or do you use some notion of
density so number of points and
different regions of the feature space
and of course what kind of data you're
looking at so do you look at a let's say
cross-sectional data set or do you have
spatial data where you have an index
that that you know has a higher
Dimension is it an ordered problem or
even a graph problem so
so yeah very much jumping into the
algorithm so
um
Bayesian histogram anomaly detector
um give you a brief motivation
around where we have come up
um with this Approach at Alliance we
were facing let's say the challenge that
in a corporate Insurance context
um we wanted to deploy on a global scale
really for different countries
um a fraud predictive model and at that
time in that business we didn't have any
let's say established business process
in place so there were no labels at all
so this call somehow for an for an
unsupervised approach and
you know it's very common practice in
particular if you focus on an on an
unsupervised approach that you should
consider um an ensemble
um for this uh for this task and um
for any black box models in particular
when it's unsupervised and even more
complicated when it's an ensemble
explainability is very tricky and is
very crucial of course in in particular
in Practical applications when you when
you think of personal data
so the user wants always a reason why a
certain score is like this so
um for this reason we were looking
somehow for a sort of a surrogate model
a proxy model that somehow can explain
we can use on behalf of the actual
Ensemble and therefore we wanted to have
a model that's predictive on the one
hand but on the other side is really
um yeah locally or globally explainable
and um so the model that we're looking
at is as the title already suggests is a
probabilistic model of Asian model so
um let's Dive Right In so
um
let's assume we have observations which
are independently and identically
distributed from an unknown continuous
distribution
and we somehow want to estimate that
distribution and
um we discretize the support
of the random variable y so we bin it in
some sense and for the Simplicity we we
assume that in node locations are known
at the moment so
this can
very easily then motivated in in
something that we call a piecewise
constant data model
so we essentially have to face with
certain unknown parameters so you have
those spin probabilities that we denoted
by by pi this Vector pi
and um as I think all of you might know
in a histogram context it's very crucial
so to say the number of pins which is a
very crucial parameter that you have to
somehow in a statistical sense take care
of
um so this is also part of our
estimation so we really on the Fly also
estimate the unknown parameter
and through the spinning
um this somehow implies that we map the
continuous variable y i to a one hot
vector and this can be perceived as a um
yeah as a categorical distribution so
the categorical distribution is very
much you know known to be part of the
exponential family so there exists a
conjugate prior and this will be used
um
uh subsequently so
a very crucial part as I as I said is
here really this parameter K so the an
integer parameter the number of bins
because this very much controls the
complexity
um and the fit of this whole density
estimate and we um
we use an informative prior that was
proposed by Scargill 2013.
and um
we you can see from the from the form of
this prior that it depends on a hyper
parameter so there's some sort of
hierarchy here in place this
hyperparameter gamma
controls really the complexity and we
also put
prior on that parameter and this is an
uninformed in an uninformative program
that restricts gamma to the range of 0
and 1 and because this has the form of a
geometric series
this control so to say the convergent
convergence of this geometric series and
um yeah we will use this um subsequently
then
um the parameters Pi which are the bin
probabilities
um we simply use a Jeffries prior that
can be shown to be a direct layer prior
with
um yeah hyper parameters alpha one over
two
and um we integrate these parameters out
because
essentially we are facing we want to
somehow derive the posterior of the
number of pins
in order to estimate the number of pins
and therefore we have to integrate all
the parameter Vector Pi this can be done
analytically because it's a conjugate
model
and we integrate all this hyper
parameter gamma numerically which can be
done for example by important sampling
or
numerically by let's say a Simpsons rule
or things like that so
um just wanted to show you what's the
form of this
um of this informative prior
um for the number of pins and it you can
see it's highly informative because it
somehow restricts the um the number of
pins in a sense that we impose something
like ochem's razor saying that let's say
more comp simpler models are preferred
or over complex models and this is some
sort of regularization that we impose
here by this prior
um to give you a simple example how does
that work so how does the estimation
process of the number of bins work
um we
um yeah use the relatively famous
example from Larry Wasserman
which he termed the Bart Simpson density
and yeah you can see from the form of
this density uh why this somehow has
some resemblance so under the hood it's
mainly a gaussian mixture model
a five component gaussian mixture model
and it's straightforward to to take some
random draws from this so we take some
random draws from this estimate so to
say the number of pins and then compute
the histogram and on the right hand side
you can see the posterior Mass function
of the number of pins alongside with the
credible interval
um 95 highest posterior density interval
and
um what we term here as K hack base is
the maximum apostory estimate
and for comparison we show some other
let's say frequentest estimates
so in order to somehow have this a
little bit more condensed we did a
little Monte Carlo experiment
and we're repeating this whole process
that I just described so taking random
draws Computing the number of bins for
um yeah 100 times or so and doing this
also with different sample sizes to
really you know see a little bit the
sensitivity regarding the sample size
and um Computing the mean integrated
squared Arrow between the true density
and which we know obviously and
um which is a gaussian mixture model and
the estimated densities
and you can see that from the figures
that
um so the the red one is the base
estimate so this performs quite
quite decent I would say and
um when you when you aggregate
everything over the the different sample
sizes which we term here aggregated mice
then this is very close to to Scott's
rule which is a little bit better here
so this seems to work
um so actually we want to do anomaly
detection so how can we go there
for Innovation context
um obviously we need the posterior
predictive distribution
for a new data point and this is again
straightforward to to calculate because
again we are in some sort of multinomial
directly
conjugacy and we can calculate that more
or less by hand yeah so this has the
form of a categorical distribution
and this is really the probability of a
new data point being in the s
so it's
very simple to to compute and using this
posterior predictive distribution as a
score
we somehow arrive at the anomaly score
which is simply we take that as the
geometric mean
of the posterior predictive distribution
and using a log scale for let's say
numerical reasons this we arrive at a
simple arithmetic mean as you can see
and um
so this very much simplifies many things
for us first of all the computation
because it's a simple arithmetic mean so
it's linear the complexity is n times M
where M is so to say the number of bins
you know
and also allows some sort of
explainability obviously yeah because
low scores mean being outliers and vice
versa so we can simply
look at the different components yeah of
the sum and see what makes the most
contribution that's a little bit the
idea
and um
to a quick summary of the algorithm of
the bhad so overall features upper
uppercase team we compute the posterior
Mass function
um of the number of pins per per feature
and then compute the
um maximum posteriorly estimate
based on that compute sufficient
statistics which are simple counts
compute the posterior predictive
probabilities based on that do that for
all features and then finally compute
the score so it's very simple to compute
um and
so there is a
um a package available
pH ad which is available on Pi Pi so
this very much follows a well-knowns I
could learn API alongside the outline
mixing template and
[Music]
um
you can use everything that you can use
with a standard outlier mixin classes so
for example you can use pipe lines and
things like that so for example here we
use first discretize The Continuous
features in case of categorical features
this obviously will be skipped
and then compute DB hid and compute or
predict so to say some scores
um coming to the model explainability as
I already
um
yeah mentioned through the linearity you
can very easily
calculate or come up with some sort of
local explainability and for this we
have an explainer module in place
which allows the user to do that and
um for for indiv on an individual level
so really on our observational level
um you simply build the rank Series yeah
of the of the different um lock
posterior predictive
um values
and um take so to say record the feature
names and the corresponding ranks and
take this then as an explanation and
um on a global level you can very simply
average that so you take the average
rank um and then transform this to a
unit interval on a global level and
um you can visualize that in the usual
form that everyone knows on from from
Global feature importances so on the
very top you have the most important
feature and um at the bottom the less
least important one
so um coming to the model benchmarking
um we calculated
a couple of different models to compare
bhad with so
um
we took for example an isolation Forest
um one-class support Vector machines
average K and ends angle-based outlier
detector then two deep learning models
so a vanilla gaussian VA and a VA with a
direct clay process prior so the stick
breaking DEA
um the local outlier factor and then two
very simple model which is the empirical
CDF
um a histogram based outlier detection
which as the name suggests is very very
similar to the one that we are using but
on our purely frequenter spaces and
doesn't
um obviously give straightforward
inference regarding this
a crucial parameter of number of pins
and then an ensemble
um so full of sample the taking the
minimum rank
um of these scores and a boosted boosted
ensemble
um I'm presenting here evidence from
from uh for simulated data
as well as to
um yeah commonly known Benchmark data
sets so for the simulator data we simply
took random draws from a 30 variate two
components student T mixture
two components because on the one hand
we have so to say the inliers and the
outliers and through the mixture
approach we have the latent assignments
and so we can mimic a little bit the
situation in a binary classification
task
and use the the standard instruments
that we would use in our in our let's
say supervised our context
and in order to
um
yeah really control a little bit for the
uncertainty due to
um train and test split we do some yeah
Monte Carlo kind of averaging for
different training test splits let's say
100 times and you average cf1 scores
and um the other two data sets so the
pin digits
um
handwritten pintages classification data
set and the Wisconsin breast cancer data
sets which we simply so we take one
class down sample that class and the
other one the other classes are so to
say inliers this is also a common
approach so to say in the outlier
literature and
um here in red
you can see that the pH ID does a quite
um yeah favorable job I would say
um so it is
um here for the simulated it's among the
top four and for the other one it's
among the top three so
um again while having really local
explainability
um
yeah
finally we we wanted to show what is so
to say the
um
how how
Associated are are those different
um others different candidate models
when you think of an ensemble for
example you want to take an ensemble out
of all these candidate models and yeah
it's interesting to see how correlated
are the different candidates because if
they were
um not correlated at all then it doesn't
make sense to to use that as a proxy
model and you can see a bhad here in the
third column from the left hand side
it's very much correlated with those
candidates that we just showed and even
I mean obviously with let's say the
histogram based um in the top row and
the empirical CDF which is
somehow to be assumed because they they
both estimate the density in some sense
but also with more complex models like
for example in the top row the direct
clay process vea which is a completely
different approach to ours it's a deep
learning approach and yeah
um but even with such an approach
um
has a very high experiments rank
correlation so
this can be taken as some sort of
justification to take this as a proxy
model
so to sum up
um
I've just introduced pH ID pH ID
automatically determines the optimal
number of bins
allows also using mixed data it has
competitive performance compared to
state-of-the-art methods it allows local
and Global model extendability due to
the linearity and sample size
and there is a python implementation
bhadim which can be used by a Pi Pi and
one of the
let's say on our discussion basis one of
the current assumptions is that the node
positions are known which is obviously
some sort of simplification
and that they are equally spaced and
this might lead to some potential
inefficiencies because for imagine for
example you have a high density region
and this high density region you assign
too low number of bins so you kind of
over smooth that region yeah and on the
other hand you might have let's say a
low density region and you assign too
many bins so you introduce way too much
variance so you somehow overfit that
that region so this is something
that is future work definitely there are
many approaches that you can apply for
example Bayesian blocks which is a
commonly known method for for this kind
of problem so this is really a
future work
so this was it thanks for your attention
thank you very much for this very
thorough and nicely explained talk
um there are three questions
how weak does it scale in the number of
features
yes
um the number of features
[Music]
um
you could see is so to say
um just to sum over those spins
so let me
ah
a
there you go so um
did you have continuous data yeah then
so to say the features are the different
pins you know so
the number of pins equals the number of
features in on a continuous level
however if you have categorical data
then yeah
the different levels uh so to say your
your different features and as you can
see they are in in some sense linear
here yeah so yeah
okay thank you another the problem with
anomaly detection is often putting it
into practice with a low amount of false
positives how are you using this method
at Allianz yes isn't a secret yes
um
important question critical yes
um obviously I mean it's an unsupervised
method yeah
um on simulated data the world is always
beautiful some somehow
um
yeah
um that that was let's say a first
approach that we used in Alliance for
that and um you know over time we
collected labels and uh we switched them
to a pure learning approach actually
yeah because we gathered positives and
so we could switch to a pure learning
approach and finally to an imbalanced
supervised approach yeah
thank you
um
did I understand this correct that phad
considers each feature Dimension
individually or does it also take into
account unusual combinations of features
yes no that's correct it's another
simplification of course makes
computation
um easier and also introduces of course
this linearity without this linearity
you have a problem with the local
expandability of course that that's a
simplification but
networks quite well so far and on the
benefit of having this local
explainability yes
and the last one can you explain bhad in
a short sentence for a not statistical
person that would be nice
that's mean
same question yes yes
um
well yeah I would say
[Music]
um
you simply count
the number of observations in that have
a certain
value yeah in a certain pin yeah
probably after Define what a business
but well it's it's a simple account
method under the hood yeah you count the
important ones
yes yes I mean yeah it's a it's a
directly approach so yeah the sufficient
statistic is that is that okay sorry
obviously
thank you very much unless there are no
other questions
let's thank all the speakers again
[Applause]